they've waited and now it's finally here
much needed aid touched down at the most
devastated area of this destructive
earthquake
it's in
where officials believe most of the
lives have been lost and it's also here
where most have been injured
in the gyan district 300 people have
been martyred 500 to 600 people have
been injured and 12 000 houses have been
destroyed as a result of this earthquake
the extent of damage is evident but the
slow response to get vital supplies
including medical attention has meant
only now four days on people are
receiving treatment
five members of my family were injured
my house is destroyed and we're facing
many problems we need all kinds of
support and we request the international
community and afghans who can help to
come forward and help us
but this is a call we've heard time and
time again the aid agencies that
remained in afghanistan after the
taliban took over last year have reacted
but only within their capabilities
this country's infrastructure has been a
major barrier but its isolation from the
world has been an even bigger one
in the capital kabul the government
believes the financial sanctions imposed
by the us on the taliban
is the greatest barrier of all the
problems come from the 20-year
occupation
and it stems from the
the lack of basic infrastructure that
has not been built over the last 20
years
and as for the resources part it's the
sanctions
as the sanctions as the asset freezes
and it's the callous attitude afterward
if we look at the sanctions if we look
at the collective punishment our track
record is actually
many many many times better than what
they have so talking about moral
superiority ours is here
and there is is in the gutter
but the taliban have broken promises
their pledge to allow all girls to go
back to school was ditched last year a
policy which set back any hopes of
diplomatic ties and it's a move seen by
some officials as shooting themselves in
the foot
and ultimately could be the reason for a
limited international response to this
disaster
despite all the political noise which is
hard to ignore at the heart of this
tragedy are people people who've been
waiting for help
people who've lost everything intimate
rasheed sky news in kabul